>> IS THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER IN
AFGHANISTAN NOW INEVITABLE?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE AFGHAN
TROOPS HAVE 300,000
WELL-EQUIPPED, AS WELL EQUIPPED
AS ANY ARMY IN THE WORLD AND AN
AIR FORCE AGAINST SOMETHING LIKE
75,000 TALIBAN.
IT IS NOT INEVITABLE.
>> HERE'S WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
THE TALIBAN WILL BEGIN TO MASS
AT SOME POINT TO TAKE DOWN THE
MAJOR CITIES IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE HOLDING BACK NOW UNTIL
THE UNITED STATES IS PRETTY MUCH
ALL GONE AND THEN WE WILL SEE
THAT.
>> Shannon: LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL TO DISCUSS THAT MOLLIE
HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR AT "THE
FEDERALIST," HAROLD FORD JR.,
FORMER TENNESSEE CONGRESSMAN AND
CEO OF EMPOWERMENT AND INCLUSION
CAPITOL AND BILL McGURN
COLUMNIST FOR THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
LET'S START RIGHT THERE, MOLLIE,
THE PRESIDENT SAID A COUPLE OF
THINGS HE DOES NOT TRUST THE
TALIBAN.
HE ALSO SAYS, LISTEN, THEY ARE A
SMALLER FORCE, ONLY 75,000
VERSUS POSSIBLY HUNDRED THOUSAND
IN THE AFGHAN ARMY.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE EVEN WITH THEIR
SMALLER NUMBERS.
>> THIS IS REALLY ABOUT SO MUCH
MORE.
IT'S ABOUT HOW WE FIGHT WARS AND
WHAT WE'RE THINKING.
ALMOST 20 YEARS AGO THAT OUR
FRIEND CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER GAVE
A SPEECH IN WHICH HE SAID IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO SPREAD
DEMOCRACY FROM NORTH AFRICA TO
AFGHANISTAN.
HE NOTED THAT MANY CONSERVATIVES
THOUGHT IT WOULDN'T WORK.
HE SAID IT MIGHT NOT WORK BUT HE
THOUGHT WE SHOULD GIVE IT A TRY.
WE HAVE GIVEN IT A TRY.
WE HAVE GIVEN IT A VERY LONG
TRY.
IT HAS COST TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE'S LIVES HAVE
BEEN LOST.
AND THE NATION OF AFGHANISTAN
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
EVEN AFTER WE HAVE INVESTED SO
MANY RESOURCES.
BUT, REALLY WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS
THAT THE UNITED STATES
UNDERSTANDS THE WAY THAT WE
FIGHT WARS, WE HAVE TO HAVE
CLEAR METRICS OF SUCCESS.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHY WE ARE
THERE.
WE HAVE TO MOVE AWAY FROM
NATION-BUILDING INTO FIGHTING
WARS THAT ARE SOLELY IN OUR
NATIONAL INTEREST.
LASER-FOCUSED ON OUR NATIONAL
INTEREST.
ALL THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THINGS ARE GOING TO GO IN
AFGHANISTAN I THINK, MISS THAT
POINT THAT WE TRIED THIS
EXPERIMENT AND IT DID NOT WORK.
>> Shannon: AND THE PRESIDENT
WAS ASKED TODAY ABOUT WHETHER
THIS WAS A MISSION ACCOMPLISHED
MOMENT.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK PEOPLE
ACROSS THE WORLD AND CERTAINLY
HERE AT HOME AND AMERICA WANT TO
HEAR DID.
WE ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING?
WHAT DID WE ACCOMPLISH?
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
ON THAT POINT.
>> IS THIS A MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED MOMENT?
WHAT IS IT?
>> NO, THERE IS NO POLITICIAN
ACCOMPLISHED THE MISSION WAS
ACCOMPLISHED IN THAT WE GOT
USAMA BIN LADEN AND TERRORISM IS
NOT EMANATING FROM THAT PART OF
THE WORLD.
>> Shannon: BUT, HAROLD, HOW
CONCERNED SHOULD WOULD HE BE NOW
THAT SOME OF THOSE FORCES CAN
RECONFIGURE THERE IT'S NOT JUST
THE U.S. LEAVING OTHER GOOD
ACTORS LEAVING A VERY TROUBLED
AREA.
OR BILL, I THINK HAROLD IS
HAVING A LITTLE TROUBLE -- OKAY,
HAROLD, GO AHEAD.
>> SORRY.
I CAN HEAR YOU.
I AGREE LARGELY WITH THE
PREDICATE THAT MOLLIE HAS
ARTICULATED.
I THINK IT IS, YOU KNOW, 20
YEARS, $4 TRILLION.
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS THERE.
I DO THINK WE HAVE FOUND THAT
CULTURE AND PERSISTENT HISTORY
OF TRIBALISM HAS UNDERMINED OUR
EFFORTS TO BRING ABOUT THE KIND
OF UNIT OR CENTRALIZED
GOVERNMENT IN AFGHANISTAN THAT
WE WANT.
BUT, ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
MOLLIE'S POINT 20 YEARS LATER
TECHNOLOGY HAS GROWN,
SATELLITES, DRONES, WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROSECUTE THIS EFFORT.
PROTECT OUR INTEREST AND ENSURE
THE ONE THING WE DON'T WANT TO
SEE HAPPEN WHICH IS THAT --
THOSE GROUNDS THERE IN
AFGHANISTAN, THE TALIBAN, AGAIN,
BECOMING A HAVEN FOR TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS.
IF THAT HAPPENS, I WOULD IMAGINE
THIS ADMINISTRATION WOULD FOLLOW
THE LEAD OF ITSELF AND GENERAL
KEANE AND OTHERS WHO URGED WE
GET BACK ON THE GROUND THERE
BECAUSE, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
OUR FOCUS HAS TO SHIFT.
CHINA PRESENTS ITSELF AS GRAPHIC
CALL ECONOMIC AND MILITARY
THREAT THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FOCUS ON MUCH LIKE WE FOCUS
ON RUSSIA DURING THE COLD WAR IN
THE 20TH CENTURY.
>> Shannon: THE PRESIDENT TODAY
DID NOT, AS YOU NOTED, SAY THAT
WE WOULD NEVER GO BACK, AMERICAN
TROOPS WOULD NEVER BE CALLED
BACK INTO THAT ARENA.
"THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER"
WRITING ABOUT THAT SAID THIS:
THE IMPLICATION, SHOULD THE
TALIBAN FIGHT THEIR WAY BACK TO
RUNNING THE COUNTRY, WASHINGTON
MIGHT CONCLUDE THAT IT IS
ACCEPTABLE SO LONG AS IT DOES
NOT HARBOR EXTREMIST GROUPS SUCH
AS AL QAEDA, THE SLACK STATE
ISLAM MIC STATEGROUP, THROWS USE
CALCULATIONS WE ARE ALWAYS
HAVING TO MAKE HOW MUCH WE LET
THE QUOTE, UNQUOTE, BAD GUYS
HAVE A SAY OR, YOU KNOW, A HAND
IN RUNNING THE COUNTRY WHEN WE
HAVE WORRIES ABOUT THINGS THAT
WILL IMPACT OUR INTEREST OR
THOSE OF OUR OF A LIES.
>> YEAH, LOOK, SHANNON, I WAS IN
AFGHANISTAN WITH THE HUGE
GENTLEMAN DEAN WAY BACK BEFORE
THIS WAR IN THE FIRST WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN WHEN THEY WERE
FIGHTING THE SOVIETS.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER
VIETNAM.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER THE
REFORMATION OF LIKE ISIS AFTER
WE LEFT THE AREA.
I WISH I COULD ON MYSTIC BUT I
CAN'T.
THE LAST TIME WE THOUGHT
AFGHANISTAN DIDN'T MATTER, YOU
KNOW, THEY CAME AND KNOCKED DOWN
TWO OF OUR BUILDINGS IN
MANHATTAN.
AND ATTACKED THE PENTAGON.
AND I JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THE AIR CAPABILITIES ARE GOING
TO BE SUFFICIENT.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED IN BENGHAZI
BECAUSE OUR FLIGHT -- IT TOOK
HOURS FOR FLIGHTS TO GET THERE.
I JUST DON'T THINK YOU CAN
SUBSTITUTE FOR TROOPS ON THE
GROUND.
WE H I BELIEVE, THREE CASUALTIES
THIS YEAR.
NONE OF THEM COMBAT RELATED.
WE ARE STILL IN GERMANY AFTER
DEFEATING HITLER.
AND WE ARE IN KOREA AND JAPAN
AFTER WORLD WAR II.
AND THAT'S BEEN TO OUR BENEFIT
TO HELP STABILIZE THE REGION.
I JUST THINK THIS IS GOING TO GO
DOWN AS A TERRIBLE MISTAKE.
>> Shannon: THE PRESIDENT DID
TALK, TOO, ABOUT THESE CAUCUSES
ABOUT WHY TO GET OUT AND WHEN TO
GET OUT.
I WILL PLAY A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY ON THAT FRONT
TODAY.
>> THE U.S. MILITARY MISSION IN
AFGHANISTAN CONTINUES TO THE END
OF AUGUST.
LET ME ASK THOSE WHO WANT US TO
STAY.
HOW MANY MORE -- HOW MANY
THOUSANDS MORE AMERICANS,
DAUGHTERS AND SONS, ARE YOU
WILLING TO RISK?
I WILL NOT SEND ANOTHER
GENERATION OF AMERICANS TO WAR
IN AFGHANISTAN WITH NO
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF
ACHIEVING A DIFFERENT OUTCOME.
THE UNITED STATES CANNOT AFFORD
TO REMAIN TETHERED TO POLICIES
CREATING A RESPONSE TO A WORLD
AS IT WAS 20 YEARS AGO.
>> Shannon: MOLLIE, THAT GETS TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT TRYING AN
EXPERIMENT, SEEING WHETHER IT
WORKS, WHAT OUR ROLE IS THERE.
DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
ARTICULATED WELL ABOUT THE
REASONING FOR LEAVING NOW?
>> I ACTUALLY THINK HE DID A
GREAT JOB WITH IT I WANT TO
COMMEND HIM FOR STAYING STRONG
AFTER SO MUCH PRESSURE FROM THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX.
ALSO THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SET
THAT DEADLINE WHICH HELPED GET
THIS GOING IS VERY GOOD.
MORE THAN ANYTHING THOUGH, IT'S
A REMINDER, TOO, ABOUT HOW THAT
SAME MILITARY, HOW THE BRASS DID
NOT DO A GOOD JOB OF PREPARING
FOR EXIT.
ONE OF THE WAYS THEY KEPT US
THERE FOR SO LONG WAS BY NEVER
REALLY DEVELOPING A STRATEGY FOR
HOW TO LEAVE AND IT WOULD TRAP
PRESIDENTS INTO STAYING AND WE
ARE SEEING SOME OF THE FALLOUT
OF THAT NOW.
BUT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS DOING A
GREAT THING YOU BY NOT ALLOWING
THAT TO CONTINUE AND INSISTING
WE STICK WITH THIS PLAN AND
HOPEFULLY THINGS WILL GO WELL
FROM HERE ON OUT.
IT WAS LONG FOUGHT FOR BY MANY
PEOPLE SO KUDOS TO HIM.
>> Shannon: THE WHOLE IDEA IS
GETTING TOURS AND GETTING
POLITICAL PEACEFUL SOLUTION TO
THIS WHOLE THING, BUT, HAIRED,
WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY THEY
CAN'T TRUST THE TALIBAN AS, YOU
KNOW, A NEGOTIATING PARTNER AT
THE TABLE, HOW DOES THAT
RESOLUTION EVENTUALLY COME
ABOUT?
>> RIGHT.
IF WE STAYED INDEFINITELY OR
STAYED A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
I DON'T MEAN TO PUT WORDS IN
BILL'S MOUTH.
IF WE STAYED, THE TALIBAN IS NOT
GRADUALLY BECOMING A MORE
TRUSTWORTHY ORGANIZATION.
WHAT WE ARE FINDING IS WE HAVE
OTHER PRIORITIES.
WE CAN MANAGE THE SITUATION WITH
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND HOPEFULLY WE
DON'T HAVE TO FIND OUR WAY BACK
THERE BUT I THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT'S A PAINFUL, IT'S A TOUGH
DECISION.
AND I EXPECT THE MILITARY TO
COUNTER THE PRESIDENT SOME ON
THIS.
BUT HOPEFULLY THEY REACH AN
AGREEMENT IN OUR MILITARY AND
WHITE HOUSE THAT IF THERE IS A
PROBLEM WE CAN GET BACK AND GET
BACK QUICKLY AND LET'S HOPE WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK AND WE ARE
ABLE TO MANAGE THE SITUATION AND
GET ON TO DEALING WITH CHINA AND
OUR OTHER FOES.
>> Shannon: QUICK CLOSING
COMMENT TO YOU, BILL, ON THIS
TOPIC?
>> WELL, WEREN'T THE SOUTH
VIETNAMESE REASSURED IF
SOMETHING HAPPENED THE U.S.
WOULD BE BACK THERE TO DO IT.
I'M NOT SURE OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY HELPED MUCH IN
BENGHAZI WHEN THOSE GUYS WERE
OUT OF REACH OF AIR SUPPORT.
I HOPE THEY ARE RIGHT.
BUT I, AGAIN, THIS LOOKS TO ME
LI